E aí
e imagina em dois homens com a mesma
idade que vivem na mesma cidade
os dois são casados cada um deles tem
duas filhas
eles torcem para o mesmo time de futebol
e os dois tem um histórico de doença
cardíaca na família
é um deles trabalha trabalha numa
multinacional tem um plano de saúde
O outro tem um emprego informal a renda
um pouco menor Eles não conseguem pagar
um seguro saúde
e hoje de manhã mas o mesmo mais ou
menos ao mesmo tempo esses dois homens
que são tão parecidos é tão diferentes
ao mesmo tempo ele se sentiram não está
e procuraram atendimento de saúde
e um deles morreu hoje de tarde
é o que o exame que era necessário para
fazer o diagnóstico demorou demais para
ficar pronta
se Vocês conseguem adivinhar quem foi
que morreu
o quanto é melhor você se sentem
confortáveis em saber a razão de porque
um deles morreu
Hum será que normal a gente aceitar que
as pessoas morrem às vezes simplesmente
porque elas não puderam pagar por um bom
tratamento de saúde
Hum será que é natural a gente aceitar
que a vida de uma pessoa é diretamente
proporcional à quantidade de dinheiro
que ela tem no banco
e essa história que eu acabei de contar
ela é obviamente fictícia uma obra de
ficção mas ela inspirado em fatos reais
faz o que acontece no Brasil e que
acontece no mundo todos os dias a todo
momento em algum lugar do planeta alguém
morre alguém vive porque tinha ou não
dinheiro para pagar para a saúde e a
gente vai vivendo desse jeito
no Brasil se você tem um plano de saúde
você vai fazer 15 exames por ano ao
custo total de 271 reais pelo sistema
agora que você faz parte do 160 milhões
de brasileiros que não têm a sorte de
ter um bom plano de saúde o sistema de
saúde vai gastar com você apenas 23
reais para todos os seus exames
O que significa que o sistema de saúde
gasta 12 vezes menos dinheiro com 76 por
cento da população
isso não é uma característica única do
Brasil essa história que eu contei no
começo ela pode ser adaptado para
qualquer país ela faz sentido no Brasil
ela faz sentido na Argentina nos Estados
Unidos na Europa na África e temos um
pouquinho um detalhe aqui um detalhe ali
o time e que cada um tosse mas no final
pessoas vão viver e vão morrer
dependendo da quantidade de acesso que
elas têm essa Hoje
os exames laboratoriais eles influenciam
setenta por cento das decisões médicas
eles representam 94% dos dados objetivos
e saúde eles são necessárias em mais de
trinta e sete porcento dos protocolos 1
Protocolos de atendimento médico
o e mesmo assim uma grande parcela da
população do mundo não têm acesso a eles
e a gente vive de certa forma um
Apartheid de saúde onde a distância
entre a saúde dos mais ricos dos mais
pobres é cada vez maior se você procurar
no Google por tendências e Medicina
Diagnóstica vocês vão encontrar palavras
como epigenética
proteômica genômica
Wellness Bill marcadores sequenciamento
genético de Nova Geração medicina
personalizada
agora se você usar o mesmo Google para
procurar estatísticas de saúde vocês vão
descobrir que 6 milhões de pessoas no
mundo não sabe que vivem com HIV que
mais de 200 milhões de pessoas no mundo
não sabe que tem diabetes e só no Brasil
4 milhões de pessoas não sabem que tem
hepatite
o que mais de sessenta e sete porcento
da população mundial não conhece os
próprios níveis de colesterol no Japão
vocês vão descobrir que as pessoas vivem
até os 84 anos em média mas não lesoto
Elas moram 50 anos se você tiver
dinheiro você pode contratar um serviço
para se conhecer a todo o seu Genoma e
descobri uma doença que vai te matar
daqui 20 ou 30 anos por outro lado a
diarreia é a oitava causa de morte no
mundo a terceira em crianças a gente
vive no mundo desigual E essa distância
essa desigualdade ela aumenta a cada
nova tecnologia que é criada em saúde e
que não é distribuída para todas as
pessoas a gente vive numa bolha tão
confortável que a gente tem um
privilégio de discutir Qual é o melhor
exame Qual o melhor laboratório até
mesmo Qual é a melhor vacina no mundo
onde não tem nem exames nem laboratórios
em vacinas para todo mundo
O que é isso esta forma é esquisito
discutir Qual é o melhor tipo de exame
certo porque seria a gente mede ele como
pela especificidade
pela acurácia
pela sensibilidade
e eu vou dar um exemplo pra vocês um
exame com quem exame na verdade de
hepatite tem uma couraça de peso de 99
concentro qualquer exame de sífilis que
você encontra em qualquer laboratório do
mundo vai ter uma curada perto de
noventa e nove porcento mesmo assim no
mundo 290 milhões de pessoas não sabem
que têm hepatite e 80 mil bebês
recém-nascidos nascem com sífilis
congênita isso não acontece porque os
exames tem uma curar se abaixa isso
acontece com os exames são ruins isso
acontece simplesmente porque os exames
não chegam a todas as pessoas do mundo
e eu acredito que um bom exame ou melhor
exame não é só aquele que tem uma boa
Croácia eu acredito que o melhor exame é
aquele exame que foi feito aquele exame
que foi realizado e se você parar para
pensar o que é a sensibilidade o
acurácia verdadeiras de um exame que
nunca foi feito
e hoje eu vou mostrar para vocês um
projeto que envolve vários tipos de
tecnologia internet das coisas
inteligência artificial telemedicina
e esse projeto foi desenhado para criar
um novo tipo de telemedicina ele de
Medicina Diagnóstica eu não vou
apresentar para vocês uma tecnologia que
foi desenhada para ser usado no terceiro
mundo eu não vou apresentar para vocês
uma tecnologia que foi criada para ser
usada em consultórios chiques do
primeiro eu vou perguntar para você
simplesmente uma nova forma de fazer
exames uma nova ideia sobre como a gente
pode usar a tecnologia a Inovação para
criar um novo tipo de sistema de saúde
onde a todas as pessoas têm o mesmo tipo
de acesso
é isso aqui é um laboratório
Ah e não dispositivo conectado à
Internet
que é controlado por uma inteligência
artificial que roda na nuvem do outro
lado da nuvem a gente tem um sistema de
remoto comandado também por uma equipe
de especialistas em análises clínicas
Isso significa que você consegue fazer
um exame de sangue em qualquer lugar sem
precisar ter um especialista de análises
clínicas ali o profissional de saúde
pode estar 5000 km ou 10.000 Km km de
distância um paciente e mesmo assim
realizar o exame ele funciona com
cápsulas como essa onde cada cápsula não
representa um tipo de exame diferente a
ideia muito simples você escolhe qual é
o exame ou basicamente Qual é a cápsula
você coleta amostra biológica que pode
ser soro sangue da ponta do dedo pode
ser plasma saliva fezes urina o swab
nasal e assim por diante fossem série A
cápsula dentro do equipamento Oi
e a partir daí o sistema trabalha
sozinho a reação química que acontece
dentro da cápsula ela é digitalizada por
equipamento ela enviada para nuvem onde
sistema de Inteligência Artificial
Analisa vários parâmetros na verdade
isso milhares de parâmetros depois disso
uma equipe de especialistas em análises
clínicas tomar uma decisão final
acompanhando todo esse processo o laudo
chega por paciente e mais ou menos 15
minutos na maioria dos exames o
equipamento foi criado para permitir
várias metodologias diferentes Então
hoje nessa plataforma a gente já
consegue rodar metodologias como química
seca colorimetria e
mundo cromatografia imunofluorescência
PCR Lamp e até mesmo microscopia digital
E com isso a gente tem que seguir fazer
diversos tipos de exames diferentes
gravidez vitamina de dengue Zika
chicungunha TSH hemoglobina glicada
glicemia
colesterol triglicerídios creatinina
ureia e ácido úrico e o vídeo também
hoje a gente tem mais de 40 tipos de
exames diferentes rodando e a ideia aqui
nos próximos meses ou anos a gente chega
mais de 100 tipos de exames diferentes
e esse é um projeto que já tem sido
desenvolvido há quase cinco anos
EA cada dia que passa essa tecnologia
fica mais poderosa e mais próximo de um
laboratório de análises clínicas
tradicional no nosso último estudo de
correlação clínica esse laboratório esse
mini laboratório foi comparado com o
laboratório certificado no College of
American pathologists o caps é uma das
principais organizações de análises
clínicas do mundo em um estudo que
envolveu
3.625 amostras
e o estudo concluíram que a gente tem
uma uma resultados muito bons é que
obteve uma acurácia de 99. 27 por cento
uma sensibilidade de 98.1 35% uma
especificidade de 99. 51 por cento uma
correlação com os resultados do
laboratório de 94 por cento e um
coeficiente Kappa de maior que zero. 99
o que significa estatisticamente os dois
resultados os dois estados tem uma
correlação clínica quase perfeita
é mas a pergunta de verdade que fica é
Funciona porque Como disse agora a pouco
não adianta a gente tem uma acurácia de
99. 27 por cento esse exame não chega na
ponta
e
a gente tem desenvolvido testes nos
últimos anos pensando sempre numa ideia
muito muito simples resolver quatro
problemas da Saúde Mundial
a mortalidade infantil a mortalidade
materna as doenças transmissíveis e as
doenças crônicas todos os exames que
estão sendo desenhados estão sendo
desenhados pensando nesse nesses quatro
problemas
pra gente medir o impacto disso nos
últimos anos a gente estalou milhares
esses pequenos Laboratórios e mais de
mil cidades do Brasil
e hoje mais de cinquenta por cento da
população brasileira vive há menos de 6
km de um desses mini Laboratórios E com
isso a gente tem conseguido fazer
milhões de anos e com esses milhões de
exames a gente tem colecionado cada vez
mais histórias que mostram de verdade o
impacto e respondi de fato a pergunta se
funciona ou não funciona por exemplo a
15 dias atrás Aí estava numa aldeia
indígena no meio da Amazônia testando
alguns pacientes
e uma das pacientes ela tinha 16 anos e
estava perdendo a visão
tô fazendo uns testes a gente descobriu
a causa sífilis congênita
e com o diagnóstico agora agora ela pode
receber o tratamento e se tudo der certo
ela vai recuperar a visão dela essa é o
tipo de coisa que acontece quando a
gente leva um laboratório para lugares
onde os exames não costumam ser feitos
claro que a tecnologia funciona e um
local mais comum para isso um
consultório como que a maioria de nós
tem acesso mas é muito mais interessante
ver quando a gente sai desse consultório
e vai para um lugar como esse no meio do
Sertão no meio do Nordeste aqui a gente
tem a sua milhares de pessoas muito
adultos onde muitos adultos que nunca
tinham feito o exame de sangue na vida
entre descobriu aqui diabetes
dislipidemias e assim por diante
Esse é o tipo de impacto real que
descentralizar o laboratório traz para a
saúde a van de Mia obviamente tem sido
uma prova de fogo a gente tem testado
milhões de pacientes o
imprezy ndios favelas Quilombos posso de
saúde
consultórios aldeias indígenas
é todo tipo de lugar que você puder
imaginar E a gente tem descoberta que é
possível criar um novo tipo de mundo
você já parou para pensar
em um laboratório onde você vem na fila
um Yanomami o empresário o professor e
policial uma pessoa privada de liberdade
um quilombola
e todo mundo junto ali na mesma fila
esperando o mesmo resultado o mesmo
exame tem na mesma experiência o mesmo
tipo de acesso à saúde eu tenho visto
isso todos os dias de forma virtual não
é um laboratório físico não é o único
lugar ele acontece na internet mas ele
tem ele ele é real no sentido de que a
gente entrega a saúde
e a quando me mostrou para a gente uma
cor uma verdade Cruel que esse sistema
segregado de saúde que funcionou de
certa forma tão bem para uma parte da
população do mundo ele não funciona mais
o convite mostrou para a gente que se a
gente quiser manter dois sistemas de
saúde um pelos ricos e para os pobres
Mas vamos ser problemas a gente viu que
acontece quando a saúde de Manaus falha
e São Paulo sentir isso aí teve o que
acontece quando uma variante que surgiu
na Índia aterroriza o uma pessoa que
mora na Inglaterra é que tem visto o
impacto que é deixar pessoas sem saúde
em algum em qualquer lugar do mundo
e eu acredito gente que o futuro da
saúde ele não passa só pela criação de
novas tecnologias eu acredito que o
futuro da saúde não passa só pela
criação de novos tipos de diagnóstico eu
acredito que o futuro da saúde ele tá
totalmente sentado no uso de tecnologias
que levem saúde para todos para quem
precisa não é sobre a gente fazer mais
exames é somente fazer menos exames para
mais pessoas é sobre descentralizar a
saúde É sobre democratizar o acesso no
final do dia sobre equidade
E se a gente fizer isso a gente vai
construir o mundo Unity não precisa
justificar que alguém morreu porque não
tinha acesso à saúde obrigado